[Music]
let's play this guy
his rating is not that high yet but um
let's see maybe he will
[Music]
put up very good resistance so d4 d5
let's play knight c3
and b super 4
so we are basically playing italian with
uh
not calories reverse but sort of flanks
reversed
he played e6 what do you play here
knight b5 maybe not
i thought it might be fine but maybe it
is not
okay he's out of the book definitely we
have a chance
she
knight a6 is worldwide trying to provoke
and then he starts uh playing
normal way pretending this knight on
on a6 is sort of misplaced
and sometimes you try to get some
straightforward attack as white by
playing knight t5 g4 g5
h4 and so on
we'll see if we'll manage
anyway first we need to wait for uh for
castling
and he knows how to castle okay then we
go 95
and then this plane has some potential
to
to become reality i would say
yeah now it's a 7 let's say bishop d3
then g4
we could also bring this a1 rook to h3m
this would be interesting as well
it may sound unreal but
wait a little
we'll try to get it
yeah the problem is that he's not
playing museum so he'll probably
he'll probably lose on time before i
even play 804
or maybe i disconnected this could also
be the case
the internet is not ideal with my place
guys so yeah
he plays g6 okay so let's play a4
then play h4
then rook h3 will try to confuse him
playing on both flanks
i guess it's quite safe to promote h4
actually
like c5 h4 cd92 is still good for white
all right now i'll promote rook a3
you need to be insane to play knight b5
here i would say
nah he'll probably lose some time yeah
[Music]
thanks for the game and also sorry for
uh for vlogging